foreign
in Phoenix Arizona what's up Lauren
how we doing good how are you I mean I
don't know that I can be doing better
like how's Phoenix
oh it's actually not as not as bad of a
summer as a lot of them so can't
complain very cool my family back in
Texas yesterday was 111 and I thought oh
man that is that is early to be that hot
so I I wish you all the best this summer
thank you so what's up how can I help
well my big question is my husband has
clinical depression and just wondering
what I can do to take better care of
myself oh man that's hard how long you
been married
we are going on 11 years now
how long has he been um struggling
um since he was a teenager okay
so just talk go ahead he was diagnosed
when he was a teenager but he struggled
with it probably since middle school age
um
it was something when we were dating
that he told me about but kind of said
you know it wasn't a big deal and it was
mentioned once and then
um after we were married I found out
that it's a very big deal
not that it would have been a deal
breaker but it was
um something I did not know how to
handle
so
paint us a picture of what life is like
loving somebody and building a life with
somebody who
um
has been wrestling with clinical
depression for most of their life
and
um
it kind of
I took on a lot of blame for myself like
why why is this so hard it's because I'm
not doing a good enough job and in our
10 years our first 10 years of marriage
we had already moved 10 times
we are in our 11th Place in the longest
we've ever stayed anywhere and we've
been here two years now
um but it's always like feeling like if
you make a change it'll be better
um
we tried living by my family we tried
living by his family we tried
living in a better warmer environment
we've tried all kinds of different
things and I just kind of like have this
miraculous hope that things are just
going to get easier for us
and of course that doesn't always happen
do you do you recognize now after 10
moves in 10 years that's not true
yeah yeah
there's um you've probably heard me say
this on the show before but the worst
part about moving is that you go with
you
yeah and the worst part about going
around his family and your family and
the new job the new place and another
new job and then let's start our own
business and all those cool things that
just make life an adventure
is that you go with you
yeah
and so I I will high five you and love
you and be here on the phone if you want
to move again and you think something's
going to be different out there
um I'm also
fully ready to dive in if you say I'm
I'm kind of done if you say I'm kind of
done
running from this
I am
you sound tired are you tired
I'm very tired yeah what happened that
precipitated this call
was there a blow up or a scare or a
are you sure he got he got really sick
with his stomach and we've been in and
out of the ER with it and they kind of
told us it's probably anxiety related
right
um and so I've been worried about his
health a lot and he hasn't been doing
well um
I love my husband and the reason I'm
still here is because he's always trying
to do better trying to find the next
thing that helps he's been through
acupuncture he's been through all kinds
of things
the one thing I haven't gotten him to
try is counseling that's the hardest one
for him
he went through a lot of it as a child
and
doesn't feel like it helps him so he's
not willing to try it as an adult
so
oh man
so I won't get into his
um clinical depression if he wants to
call the show I'd be happy to walk down
that rabbit hole with him
um and I'd be happy to lovingly and
as I've done over the course of my
career I I'd sit with him and I'll
challenge him appropriately and love him
appropriately that's cool the person
who's on the phone with me today is you
and it's a hurting wife who's tired of
watching her husband
drown who's frustrated when you're
throwing a raft and he won't grab it but
then he yells I've got a new backstroke
that I'm gonna try and you jump in to
backstroke with him and you find
yourself further away from Shore
and then none of this stuff's working so
yeah the only person on the phone is you
and so
I'm gonna tell you a couple of hard
truths and give you some some maybe some
things to try okay
okay here's hard truth number one
you cannot cure or heal your husband's
depression with a period at the end of
that sentence
yeah you've been trying for more than a
decade and you have to stop
you've gotta you've got to stop
okay
you know it's exhausting it is and in a
really weird way it creates what I call
this inverted shame cycle
where you try to help him he knows
you're trying to help him he feels
shameful that he has to get kind of help
this kind of help from his wife which
then in somebody struggling with
clinical depression doesn't serve as a
as jet fuel it serves as you know a pile
of of soil it just buries you and that
makes you want to work harder to try to
help and you start saying yes to crazy
ideas and weird things and you're like
I'll try that I'll try that and then he
feels ashamed that you tried that you
see what I'm saying and it just creates
this inverted loop it's somebody at some
point has to break that cycle
and yeah you're the one without clinical
depression so I want to point to you is
that is that a responsibility you would
own
yeah okay here's the greatest gift you
can give your yourself
and as a result of taking care of you
your husband and your marriage okay and
that's for you to strongly and firmly
begin to create really firm boundaries
because your husband has nothing to
Anchor into right now
not that you can be his anchor forever
but he needs somebody in his life to say
I'm not moving anymore I need a home
a friend of mine when I was spinning out
and I was out of control my wife called
him one of my close buddies and he came
home and I was talking about house I'm
gonna sell this house and move to this
house and we're gonna move to this house
and by this time mind you my son had
moved more times in his childhood than I
had in my entire 35 years of life
and my buddy said dude
your wife needs a home
and that sentence was
um
like a like a
it was like a knife in my chest and so
your your husband doesn't have a friend
like that so that's going to be you
saying this is where we live and I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna consider moving for
three to five years I need to make a
home here
I need to make friends I need to have
people over to our house
here are the things I am going to do
because here's what I need I need to
exercise I need to have friends I need
to have a local church I need to have a
um a movie theater that I go to whatever
the things are in your life
um you have to be bold and willing to
say here's what I need and here is where
I am dropping anchor for a season
and because he has not experienced that
that will feel threatening that will
feel disruptive and that might send him
feeling lower
that is not your fault
yeah that's not your fault that will be
his Adventure his journey to heal in
that capacity but this is where we live
or this is my job
so that's number one number two you're
gonna have to feel guilt over resentment
and I say this all the time when it
comes to like in-laws and stuff but
you're gonna have to start saying out
loud here's what I need and here's what
I want and he might not be able to
provide that for you because he's sick
got it you were gonna go get it
you were gonna go see a counselor
you are gonna go see a marriage
counselor even if he won't go with you
you are going to make sure you go to a
dentist and a health club and you're
going to make sure that you are doing
the things that keep you well and whole
and you haven't done that for a decade
have you
you know it's it's hard why is it hard
I know it's lonely
and he is my best friend and he just
doesn't feel good and it's just hard
are you willing to give him a picture of
what
well and strength and tiny little steps
towards being
um whole look like
yeah
yeah because I think you've spent a lot
of time sitting with him in the sewage
and that's what great friends that's
what love looks like
[Applause]
Daddy I just write the ups and downs and
I feel bad when he feels bad because I
want to make him feel better and
I can't
and the greatest gift you can give him
is to get off the roller coaster
completely
just get off
yeah and it's not that you're running
from him it's that you're providing a
stable base a stable platform for him to
to Anchor into
yeah I do I don't see a path for him
being well that's not going to include
some sort of
um significant therapeutic intervention
with a counselor
and maybe he's at a point where he needs
to try his ECT or ketamine or some sort
of psychedelic I mean maybe he needs to
bring in the heavy artillery but he's
going to have to do that therapeutically
with it with a with a therapist who
knows what they're doing
yeah and there's just no path forward
yeah and I want you to hear me
seeing somebody who's suffered from
major depressive disorder or clinical
depression on the other side of some of
those
um after years of they call it
um like
I won't use those technical terms it's
depression becomes so so challenging and
to see people on the other side of this
that are looks like a light came on so I
want you to hear me say there is hope
thank you there is what I would call
radical hope friends of mine who just
quit drinking after a decade and after
some of these treatments and they're a
joy and they had kids and they're they
laugh a lot and they make fun of them
old selves like their old selves in in
in
unimaginable ways
the hard part is
you can't get him there he's gonna have
to choose that path
what you can give him though is a
real-time picture of what it looks like
and he's you're gonna break that cycle I
was talking about and everything in his
body will try to reconstruct that cycle
he might get extra low he might get
extra mean he might get extra fulfill in
the blank you can't control any of his
responses to that what you can control
is this one sentence I'm worth being
well
yeah whatever that looks like is that
fair
yeah
I'm really proud of you
I'm proud of you for loving this guy for
more than a decade in the way you have
and I'm proud of you for saying this is
as far as I can go and I don't know what
to do and I'm proud of you for calling
it's hard
I'm gonna be proud of you every step of
the way you take
um and by the way healing from
depression is I mean it's it's it's
little wins baby steps little wins
little wins little wins
tiny little steps that suddenly become
big changes over time it's like compound
interest and it's the weight of these
massive changes that keeps people locked
up and it's that's that's not how you
heal from major depression major
depression it's teeny tiny things and
it's brain chemistry and it's therapy
and it is some of these new therapies
that come out that are just looking to
be magic
and it's a wife that says I'm getting
off the roller coaster and I'm gonna be
well I'm gonna create a platform or a
foundation for you to Anchor into if you
want to and if you're willing to
hang on the line here I'm going to send
you a copy of blowing your past change
your future I want you to read that book
and I here's my promise I'll be with you
every step of the way sweetheart I'm
proud of you I'm proud of you I'm proud
of you
um
start taking care of Lauren
start taking care of Lauren because
that's the one person
you can help right now